The antipsychotics are considered safe and thats because they are not
addictive, and they are difficult to use to commit suicide. However, again, as
with all drugs there are side effects. The side effects include skin rashes,
jaundice, photo-sensitivity, meaning they're more likely to be sunburned if
they go out in the sun, low white blood cell count, and movement disorders. And
these movement disorders include tremors, muscle rigidity, a shuffling type
walk, and a mask like face. In addition they also produce Tardive Dyskinesia.
Tardive dyskinesia consists of repetitive involuntary movements of the jaw,
tongue, face and mouth. Things such as grimacing and lip smacking, and also
body tremors. Moreover, these effects may continue for months after the drug is
discontinued.